[Música]
hola soy maría clara calle por natalia
cabrera esto es a qui américa el
programa donde revisaremos en
profundidad las historias y las noticias
de nuestro continente hoy hablaremos de
la situación que enfrenta el presidente
de honduras juan orlando hernández
su hermano fue condenado en nueva york'
a cadena perpetua por narcotráfico y la
fiscalía de eeuu dice que el mandatario
también participó en el envío de drogas
al país norteamericano pero no hay
ningún cargo en contra de hernández
colombia vive una ola de desplazamientos
cerca de 5000 venezolanos han llegado a
territorio colombiano tras los combates
en la frontera binacional esto mientras
colombia enfrenta un repunte de la
violencia en los últimos días ha dejado
más de 6000 desplazados internos
en mexico la muerte de la salvadoreña
victoria esperanza salazar en medio de
un operativo de las autoridades pone
otra vez sobre la mesa la discusión
acerca de la violencia policial y
reaviva el debate sobre los feminicidios
en uno de los países latinos donde matan
más mujeres por su género
y comencemos con honduras juan antonio
tony hernández el hermano del presidente
fue condenado a cadena perpetua en un
tribunal federal de nueva york toni fue
sentenciado por haber traficado droga
entre honduras y estados unidos durante
12 años la fiscalía estadounidense
incluso calificó a honduras como un
narcoestado porque asegura que el
mandatario conspiró con su hermano el
presidente juan orlando hernández
rechaza todos los señalamientos y
oficialmente no tiene ningún cargo en su
contra en el siguiente reporte
explicaremos la situación que atraviesa
el mandatario hondureño el narcotráfico
golpea la imagen de la familia del
presidente juan orlando hernández su
hermano el ex congresista juan antonio
tony hernández fue condenado en nueva
york' a cadena perpetua tras comprobarse
que durante 12 años estuvo involucrado
en el tráfico de cocaína hacia estados
unidos durante el juicio la fiscalía
aseguró que todo el trabajo desde 2004
de 2016 con carteles de colombia
honduras y méxico todo con la protección
de su hermano el presidente hondureño al
final el juez respaldo esta postura
tony hernández tráfico más de 185
toneladas de cocaína
algunas de ellas iban marcadas con sus
iniciales th pero para el presidente
juan orlando hernández todo es un
montaje en contra de su hermano me
resulta indignante
me resulta
increíble que los testimonios falsos de
asesinos confesos sean escuchados de
valorados de esa forma la trama que
envuelve el presidente no para allí
durante el juicio los fiscales
estadounidenses señalaron al presidente
hernández y lo catalogaron como un
cómplice de los crímenes de su hermano
la fiscalía incluso dijo que el
mandatario recibió millones de dólares
en sobornos de capos de la droga como el
mexicano joaquín el chapo guzmán en el
juicio contra joan y fuentes a quien la
justicia condenó por narcotráfico los
fiscales señalaron que el mandatario
hondureño era un socio de fuentes uno de
los testigos aseguró que tenía pruebas
para mostrar que juan orlando hernández
recibía cargamentos de cocaína de
colombia pero hernández niega a todos
los señalamientos incluso dijo que tenía
audios que probaban su inocencia
según el presidente la de infiltró la
reunión de unos narcotraficantes en 2013
en la que decían que hernández no iba a
tratar con ellos una de las banderas de
su gobierno ha sido precisamente la
lucha contra el narcotráfico aunque no
ha revelado los audios el mandatario
asegura que estas conversaciones prueban
que los traficantes que ahora los
señalan como socio están diciendo
mentiras
es posible negar o dudar que los narcos
están dando falsos testimonios porque la
verdad está documentada
en forma de grabaciones secretas y
fueron presentadas por la dea en un
juicio aunque los fiscales de estados
unidos y varios narcotraficantes
sostienen que el presidente hondureño
está involucrado en el envío de la droga
la verdad es que juan orlando hernández
no tiene ningún proceso en su contra ni
ha sido acusado formalmente otro de los
grandes temas de honduras es la caravana
de inmigrantes que salió del país con la
esperanza de llegar a eeuu muchos de los
cientos de hondureños que intentarán
cruzar las fronteras son menores de edad
una de las grandes preguntas en este
tema es que está obligando a los niños y
a las niñas a abandonar su país el
observatorio de los derechos de la niñez
de casa alianza honduras dice que el
control que ejercen los grupos armados
en más de 500 barrios de las dos
ciudades principales contribuye a que
los menores dejen de ir a las escuelas
según el observatorio de los 3 millones
de niños y adolescentes en todo el país
que están en edad escolar sólo 800.000
tienen cobertura educativa y de esos tan
sólo 350.000 aprobaron su año lectivo
otros grandes motivos de la deserción
escolar han sido el kobe 19 y la crisis
económica que atraviesan miles de
familias todos estos factores
contribuyen a que cientos de menores de
edad de honduras quieran intentar un
mejor futuro en eeuu la migración
también golpea a la frontera entre
colombia y venezuela miles de
venezolanos llegaron al territorio
colombiano desde el estado de apure
después de más de una semana de
enfrentamientos armados esto ocurrió al
tiempo que colombia atraviesa su propia
crisis con más de 6 mil desplazados
internos por la violencia en los
departamentos de nariño y cauca como lo
explicamos en el siguiente reporte
la situación en la frontera
colombo-venezolana está más tensa que
nunca miles de venezolanos cruzaron el
río arauca que divide a los dos países
para buscar un refugio en colombia
mientras la oficina de asuntos
humanitarios de la onu habla de casi
cinco mil desplazados
la ong funda redes sostiene que son más
de seis mil pues no es usual
tenemos una situación anterior con el
tema de migración que es muy diferente
al tema que está dando orita que es de
desplazamientos y de desplazamiento
entonces no es usual que en venezuela
suceda
el ministerio de defensa de venezuela
asegura que lo que ocurre en el estado
de apure desde el 21 de marzo es un
enfrentamiento entre la fuerza armada
nacional bolivariana y grupos
irregulares armados colombianos pero los
migrantes que llegaron a colombia
cuentan una historia muy distinta no me
podía quedar porque lo están matando a
uno por lo menos a unos señores que
quedaron unos vecinos los mataron y le
pusieron un uniforme del ejército
venezolano y lo hicieron pasar por
guerrilleros fundar redes ha hecho
denuncias similares y agrega que también
ha habido bombardeos en lugares donde
viven civiles mientras que human right
watch dice tener quejas de posibles
abusos por parte de la fuerza de
seguridad venezolana pero el gobierno de
venezuela le achaca los problemas de
seguridad a la violencia que se irradia
desde colombia paralelamente al interior
del territorio colombiano hubo por lo
menos 6 mil desplazados más en el
municipio de argelia en el departamento
del cauca cerca de 2000 personas dejaron
forzosamente sus hogares tras los
enfrentamientos entre la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional
y las disidencias de las farc que se
apartaron del proceso de paz además
ocurrió un hecho que no se veía hace
años en colombia el 26 de marzo explotó
un coche bomba frente a la alcaldía del
municipio de corinto y dejó por lo menos
43 heridos y aquí sabemos que los que
están detrás de este atentado son los
bandidos de la gobierno ramos bandidos
que son de esas disidencias y los
estamos enfrentando y los seguiremos
enfrentando donde estén donde estén
porque estos actos cobardes contra la
comunidad son imperdonables
la oficina de naciones unidas ocha
asegura que también hubo estiramientos
en tres municipios más del cauca y dice
que la policía frustró otro atentado al
evitar que un camión bomba explotara en
popayán una de las ciudades principales
de la región por otra parte en el
departamento de nariño hubo un
desplazamiento de más de 4000 personas
algunas de las causas de la violencia se
explican en el informe anual que publicó
eeuu sobre la situación de derechos
humanos en colombia el primero bajo la
administración de joe biden el reporte
señala que los grupos ilegales se
disputan los espacios que dejó la
antigua guerrilla de las farc tras la
dejación de armas y que ahora están en
una guerra por el control de las rutas
del narcotráfico
ahora continuemos en méjico la muerte de
la salvadoreña victoria esperanza
salazar ha desatado una ola de protestas
en el país norteamericano por las
circunstancias en las que falleció
cuatro policías mexicanos detuvieron a
la mujer de 36 años y uno de ellos la
sometió en el piso y le puso su rodilla
en el cuello hasta asfixiarla
organizaciones feministas y a favor de
los migrantes aseguran que este es un
nuevo caso de racismo y de odio contra
la mujer el informe es de marinas
ardilla la brutalidad policial también
es sistemática en méjico donde los
abusos de las fuerzas de seguridad están
en la cotidianidad la indignación ha
sacudido el país después de la violenta
muerte de la refugiada salvadoreña
victoria salazar bajo custodia policial
de brutalidad policial es una
latinoamericana las fuerzas de seguridad
las mujeres sentimos que no nos protegen
la muerte de victoria se une a las de
alexander martínez y giovanni lópez a
manos de las fuerzas del orden mexicanas
el año pasado en noviembre de 2020 la
policía empleó munición real contra una
manifestación feminista en cancún el
pasado 8 de marzo re primero en las
marchas por el día internacional de la
mujer obras en la cream og nos y balas
de goma los datos muestran el
estructural deterioro de las
instituciones de seguridad en el país
siete de cada diez personas detenidas
sufrieron amenazas o agresiones por las
autoridades durante su arrestos según
una encuesta del instituto nacional de
estadística y geografía realizada en
2016 una situación agravada para las
mujeres que frecuentemente sufren abusos
sexuales las mexicanas reclaman al
estado una mejor protección frente a las
múltiples violencias más de 140 mujeres
han sido asesinadas en lo que va de año
la brutalidad policial implica el uso
excesivo de la fuerza física y otro tipo
de ataques que resultan innecesarios
para contener ciertas acciones esto en
ocasiones puede llevar a la muerte tal
aspecto debe ser sancionado
medidas efectivas que lo eviten a futuro
los críticos afirman que la solución del
abuso por parte de los policías
mexicanos no pasa por militarizar la
seguridad pública sino por la
construcción de cuerpos policiales cuyo
objetivo sea la prevención y no la
represión así como la mejora de las
condiciones laborales y la aplicación de
leyes efectivas para evitar la impunidad
de quienes cometen los abusos ahora
vamos al sur del continente en chile- el
gobierno de sebastián piñera propuso
aplazar las votaciones al menos durante
un mes por el incremento de los casos de
kobe 19 que tiene contra las cuerdas a
la salud del país los comicios
originalmente previstos para el 10 y el
11 de abril son para elegir a los
líderes municipales y regionales y
especialmente a los delegados que
redactarán la nueva constitución
esta última votación es una de las más
importantes porque los chilenos elegirán
entre más de 1500 candidatos a las 155
personas que serán las encargadas de
escribir la nueva carta magna del país
así se cambiara la actual constitución
que se escribió durante la dictadura de
augusto
en brasil la noticia es por cuenta del
cambio en las altas cúpulas militares y
en el gobierno la nueva crisis política
comenzó con la renuncia del canciller
ernesto araújo y los ministros de
defensa y de justicia algunos de ellos
se enfrentaron al presidente ya ir
bolsonaro por su manejo de la pandemia
el presidente respondió reemplazando a
los tres funcionarios y cambiando a
otros tres de cargos ministeriales pero
la decisión le trajo una dura
repercusión en el ala militar los
comandantes del ejército de la marina y
de las fuerzas a euro náuticas salieron
de sus cargos el gobierno dice que fue
una simple sustitución para los medios
brasileños sostienen que los comandantes
renunciaron por estar en desacuerdo con
bolsonaro y cerramos nuestro programa
con la imagen de la semana el ex policía
estadounidense derek está bien sentado
en el juzgado viendo el vídeo en el que
se muestra como él sometió a georges
floyd hasta asfixiarlo las imágenes que
se vieron en el primer día del juicio
contra el antiguo uniformado
aunque durante nueve minutos y 29
segundos
xavi puso su rodilla en el cuello de
floyd mientras el afroamericano gritaba
que no podía respirar y con estas
imágenes nos despedimos por hoy gracias
por acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
américa recuerden que pueden seguirme a
través de redes sociales en la dirección
que ven en sus pantallas soy maría jara
calle por natalia cabrera continúe
viviendo france24 france24 puntocom
[Música]